souvent du bonheur on en dit tout un tas
de choses
on dit que le bonheur est un état
d'esprit on dit aussi du bonheur
on dit aussi du fait d'être heureux que
c'est parfois comme un verre rempli à
moitié
certains le voient à moitié plein
d'autres le voient à moitié vide
j'ai tendance à dire que ça se travaille
ça se travaille derrière le fait de dire
que le bonheur est un état d'esprit il y
a un peu plus que ça et c'est ce que
j'aimerais vous expliquer aujourd'hui je
travaille sur l'entraînement cérébral
mais travaux de recherche portent sur
l'entraînement cérébral par les jeux
alors j'aimerais commencer avec vous
aujourd'hui pour vous faire un jeu et ce
jeu commence par le fait de regarder un
cube vous allez voir apparaître à
l'écran
le voici j'aimerais savoir comment vous
voyez ce cube
certains vont le voir avec la face avant
en bas à droite certains ne verront avec
la face avant en haut à gauche et
certains verront les deux pas en même
temps ça c'est une capacité que votre
esprit à que votre cerveau à de passer
d'un état à un autre
vous pourrez dire que ces cantiques
certains s'y penche aujourd'hui et je
pense qu'on en saura de plus en plus
durant les années qui viennent on peut
déjà dire qu'en faisant cette expérience
là si vous arrivez à voir les deux états
du cube vous fait déjà preuve de
flexibilité
la flexibilité c'est une capacité qu'a
votre cerveau et vous pouvez la
travailler si vous vous efforcez de
regarder une seule d'une seule manière
le cube sans par l'autre à ce moment là
vous essayé de bloquer une vision ce
blocage
on appelle ça l'inhibition
d'inhiber ce que l'on voit une partie de
ce que l'on voit sur notre capacité qu'a
votre cerveau et ses deux capacités la
flexibilité et l'inhibition peuvent vous
aider à voir la vie différemment et
c'est ce que j'aimerais vous expliquer
aujourd'hui
alors pour vous expliquer ça je vais
vous raconter une histoire qui s'est
passé il ya pas longtemps
c'est une véritable histoire cette
histoire je l' ai vécu il ya un mois
quand j'étais à grenade en espagne
je suis allé présenter mes travaux de
recherche un colloque international
j'étais super fier mais au-delà d'être
super fier eh bien on avait la
possibilité d'aller le troisième jour
visiter un monument extraordinaire tout
le monde m'avait dit moi je ne
connaissais pas tout le monde m'avait
dit elisabeth si tu vas à grenade
tu dois voir l'alhambra peut-être
certains d'entre vous connaissent cet
édifice ce monument exceptionnel 23e
jour à la fin des conférences j'ai fait
mon maximum pour assister à toutes les
conférences
mais à la fin je suis allé à l'alhambra
j'ai pris le bus le bus espagnol me
débrouillant comme je pouvais avec les
restes de ce que j'avais en espagnol et
je suis arrivé à lembras il était il
était à peu près 17 heures et j'ai
commencé la visite de l'alhambra par les
jardins ses jardins lorsque je suis
rentré il y avait une grande ali
tapissez d'arbres immenses immense ces
arbres étaient ouverts quoi parce qu'il
fut il pleuvait il pleuvait pas mal à ce
moment là il y avait encore beaucoup de
feuilles c'était début du printemps en
avançant je me suis véritablement senti
entrer dans un univers au bout de
l'allée il y avait un parterre de fleurs
c'est un véritable jardin on est passé
d'un d'un espace vertical un espace
horizontale avec un des parterres de
fleurs extrêmement colorés et en avant
sont encore un petit peu je suis passé à
côté d'une rose l'a3 lma ap pourquoi
elle m'a appelé parce qu'elle avait une
couleur une couleur qui était intense
forte et lorsque je me suis approché
autre chose m'a happé et plus sa couleur
mais son parfum et le parfum en le
sentant il était subtil
l'idée intense aussi ce moment à ce
moment là j'étais avec la fleur et
j'étais avec rien d'autre
j'ai continué ma visite et en continuant
ma visite
je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait une
autre odeur qui se dégageait dans cet
endroit là c'est 37 je n'arrivais pas
véritablement à la dc avait
véritablement à savoir ce qu'était cette
odeur et en regardant un petit peu
autour de moi je me suis dit mais qu'est
ce que c'est ça sent bon ça sent bon et
va un goût d'été il y avait une odeur
d'été c'était le chèvrefeuille le
chèvrefeuille et hélas il était
l'alhambra d'été dans les mains de
l'alhambra et il me créer du bien-être
j'en étais juste là je continue la
visite est là cette fois si j'accède
homonyme aurait alors que cet espace-là
l'alhambra le palais de l'alhambra est
constitué de différents de différents
espaces de différents bâtiments et ses
bâtiments ont tous une spécificité ceux
qui sont à la fois immense et en même
temps dans cette immensité
il y à du détail énormément de détails
le détail va de la sculpture que l'on
peut voir sur le mur et cette sculpture
elle est partout partout sur le mur
jusqu'au plafond
on a une forme d'immensité qui est mêlé
à une précision extraordinaire ça
c'était assez étonnant j'étais
émerveillé
alors quand je suis passé à côté du
magasin parce que dans tous ces beaux
sites touristiques il ya toujours un
magasin le magasin où on peut acheter
des souvenirs je me suis dit oui j'ai
envie d'acheter quelque chose parce que
même si moi j'ai été à cet endroit là
pour des raisons professionnelles sans
emmener ma famille sans emmener mon mon
conjoint sans emmener mes enfants mais
j'avais envie de rapporter quelque chose
à mon chéri de rapporter quelque chose à
mes loulous
et là je suis entré dans ce magasin et
j'avais vraiment envie de choisir
quelque chose qui alors qu'ils puissent
retranscrire l'émotion que j'avais
à voir ce palais à ressentir tout ce que
je ressentais ici et j'ai réussi à
trouver
en feuilletant un petit peu partout un
bouquin et dans ce bouquin il y avait
des belles photos il y avait les photos
qui était celle que mes yeux avait vu il
y avait une forme d'émotion qui
ressemblait à celle que j'avais ressenti
je sortis de ce magasin j'étais heureuse
mais pas j'avais pas dépenser énormément
mais j'étais heureuse même si j'avais
dépensé quand même un peu d'argent
j'avais pas fait pour moi j'avais fait
pour ce que j'aime et à la fin de à la
fin de la visite
je me suis rendu compte que j'avais pas
passer une heure au palais de l'alhambra
j'avais pas passer deux heures je vais
pas passer trois heures avait passé
quatre heures
j'avais passé quatre heures à crapahuter
d'endroit en endroit à monter des
marches sans véritablement m'en rendre
compte enfin il ya certaines marchand
même on s'en rend compte
on monte on monte on monte au monde et
puis on se dit finalement ça être
infinie sable et à chaque fois aller au
bout des marches valait le coup à chaque
fois il y avait un paysage un magnifique
paysage qui étaient là où un magnifique
bâtiment qui était là où un magnifique
jardin qui étaient là et à chaque fois
l'effort en valait la peine
à ce moment là durant toute cette
période j'ai véritablement vécu ce que
j'appelle le bonheur ce que j'enseigne
beaucoup ce dont je parle beaucoup je
l'est véritablement vécu je l' ai vécu
de différentes manières et ses
différentes manières s'exprime et
explique s'exprime par l'émotion et
s'explique grâce aux mécanismes du
cerveau est un mécanisme en fin du mois
j'aimerais vous présenter aujourd'hui ce
qui me semble expliquer ce que j'ai vécu
et ça s'appelle la dose est ce que
j'appelle la 12 alors qu'est ce que
c'est la dose c'est ce que j'ai reçu est
ce que mon cerveau a reçu durant toute
cette balade
cette dose comprend différents
neurotransmetteur qui ont été déversées
mon cerveau et ces neurotransmetteurs va
s'appelle la dopamine
l'ocytocine la sérotonine et
l'endorphine alors qu'est ce que c'est
la dopamine bas la dopamine c'est ce
qu'on peut appeler une neuro
transmetteur de la réussite ce
neurotransmetteur je m'en suis rendu
compte après mais je l' ai vécu quand je
montais les marches monter les marches
faisait l'effort et puis j'étais
peut-être un petit peu fatigué mais
j'avais envie j'avais envie de monter
ses marges pourquoi parce qu'à chaque
fois je savais que au bout du compte il
y avait quelque chose et ce quelque
chose m'apporterait du bien-être je le
savais cette dopamine vous l'avez à
chaque fois que vous faites un effort ou
que vous vous sentez que vous allez vers
la réussite moi j'appelle un petit peu
le neurotransmetteur de la réussite
parce que c'est celui qui va vous donner
des ailes c'est celui qui va vous dire
allez vas-y vas-y ça vaut le coup ce que
tu vas voir tu vas pouvoir y aller dans
le magasin lorsque j'ai acheté des corps
ce que j'ai acheté un livre et des
petits objets pour ma famille à ce
moment là j'ai fait l'expérience de
l'activation de l'ocytocine l'ocytocine
ces neurotransmetteurs de l'attachement
à chaque fois que vous rouliez à
quelqu'un à chaque fois ça peut être vos
enfants votre famille ça peut aussi être
un bon copain que vous voyez puis voilà
vous ne l'avez pas vu depuis un certain
temps et vous leurs voiliers et vous
vous dites mais mince qu'est ce que ça
fait du bien de te voir mais ça s'est un
peu d'ocytocine un peu de liens que vous
avez avec lui quand j'étais dans ce
magasin n'était pas là ma famille
n'était pas là mais j'étais en lien avec
eux pourquoi parce que je pensais à eux
pourquoi parce que j'étais avec eux à ce
moment là j'étais là mais il était là
aussi dit tu es en moi
la sérotonine c'est quand j'ai réalisé
qu'à la fin à la fin mon autre à la fin
de 2 to 2 to long périple
j'avais bien coché toutes les cases je
suis allé voir quand je suis allé voir
tous les éléments de l'alhambra que
j'avais voulu aller voir
j'étais contente de moi j'étais fier de
moi je n'ai pas perdu mon temps j'avais
fait les choses j'avais suivi
j'étais pleinement présent c'était fier
j'étais satisfait
un peu de sérotonine et enfin
l'endorphine l'endorphine vous savez
c'est les sportifs particulièrement
cette ce neurotransmetteur ces
neurotransmetteurs qui porte très bien
son nom d'ailleurs il endort la douleur
en fait il agit par contraste
vous êtes fatigués mais vous avez quand
même qu'en fait vous avez quand même
envie de continuer et puis un long
moment
vous êtes fatigués vous ne l'êtes plus
et vous ne l'êtes plus pourquoi parce
que votre corps c'est très bien géré
l'effort et vous permet de pouvoir
continuer tout en ayant un petit peu
moins mal et à ce moment là vous sentez
un petit peu de bien-être
selander film qui va donner alors au
delà de ça c'est dose la c4
neurotransmetteur qui sont là qui sont
là alors ils agissent de plein d'autres
manières mais ils agissent aussi pour
votre bien-être de ses manières là vous
avez la possibilité de les activer
et c'est là où l'entraînement cérébral
peut vous aider et l'entrée de maple
l'entraînement cérébral peut vous aider
grâce à trois mots trois mots simples
lorsque vous les mettez tous les jours
dans votre quotidien vous activer un
petit peu de cette dose de bien-être qui
va vous apporter du bonheur de
différentes manières et ces trois mots
c'est le beau c'est le bien et le bout
trois mois c'est ça 6
alors qu'est ce que c'est le beau balbo
ces savoirs s'émerveiller lebossé savoir
s'émerveiller lorsque j'étais avec cette
fleur je l' ai senti que je les ai vus
j'ai eu une forme d'émerveillement cette
forme d'émerveillement dans mon corps
qu'est ce que ça a fait ça a fait
réguler un niveau de cytokines lauréats
sont des termes biologique mais qui vont
simplement permettre à la dopamine de
mieux pouvoir être présente dans mon
cerveau et 7 dopamine pam a apporté un
petit peu de bien-être m'apporte du
bien-être quand vous avez un petit peu
d'émerveillement long quand vous
apportez de l'émerveillement va vous
activer un petit peu de votre dose et
cet énervement bonne nouvelle
vous pouvez la voir grâce à vos cinq
sens vous voyez quelque chose qui vous
émerveille
vous pouvez avoir le d de votre dose
vous vous sentez quelque chose qui vous
fait plaisir
vous aimez cette odeur tout à l'heure
franck parlait d'une odeur qui sont
beaux vous vous aimez cette odeur mais
vous avez le d de votre dos vous prenez
vous allez au restaurant vous prenez du
temps à goûter vous allez dans un bon
restaurant vous fait le choix d'aller
dans un bon restaurant et vous savourez
chaque cuiller savourer chaque
fourchette va vous avez le d de votre
dose prenez un bon verre de vin
vous avez le d de votre dose vous
écoutez alexis et sa musique toute
particulière vous avez là aussi le d de
votre dose à chaque fois que vous vous
émerveiller un petit peu vous permettez
à votre corps de pouvoir générer du
bien-être du bien-être dans votre
cerveau grâce à ces neurotransmetteurs
le bien qu est-ce que c'est le bien le
bien c'est le fait de s'appliquer et de
s'impliquer
alors ça c'est magique lorsque vous vous
appliquez et lorsque vous vous impliquez
à faire quelque chose là c'est la
sérotonine anbar vous avez cette
satisfaction qui va pouvoir arriver dans
votre cerveau et la satisfaction qu'est
ce que c'est c'est un booster à estime
de soi et ça c'est très simple vous avez
la possibilité de faire avec un tout
petit rien le simple fait d'avoir coché
les cases sur mon plan et me dire allez
j'avais envie d aller voir ça j'ai envie
d'aller voir ça j'ai envie d'aller
ouvrir ça et avoir scrupuleusement suivi
mon plan est à la fin me dire ouais je
les fais j'étais fier de moi et c'est
rien j'étais bien le simple fait d'avoir
tenu voilà tout le temps c'était rien
mais c'était bien et au quotidien vous
avez la possibilité de le faire
vous avez tous dans vos vies des petits
riens qui peuvent vous permettre de
développer ce bien est ce bien
ça peut être voilà pour une fille le
fait de bien s'appliquer à mettre son
vernis voilà vous avez réussi super fier
de vous ça pourrait être moi je le fais
de temps en temps quand j'ai su inverse
j'essaye de les suivre et bien c'est
rien safran quoi ça prend une minute et
bien une minute c'est une minute de
bonheur c'est du petit bonheur mais ça
suffit
votre corps n'a pas besoin de plus
record a juste besoin d'un petit peu de
bien-être au quotidien et le dernier
c'est le bon est ce bon là je les
trouvais quand je suis allé au magasin
me suis tourné vers les autres et les
autres c'était les miens à ce moment là
j'ai pas pensé à moi si je pensé à moi
parce que je voyais j'étais encore avec
eux j'étais encore avec avec ce
sentiment de d'émerveillement que
j'avais envie de faire partager
mais j'étais pas tourné vers moi j'étais
tournée vers les autres et quand on se
tourne vers les okapis psychologie
positive nous l'enseignent aujourd'hui
on augmente son propre niveau de
bien-être
alors certains me disent parfois oui
c'est bien enfin bon encontre tout en
tournée vers les autres ont fini par
être les esclaves des autres eh bien je
dis ok ok on peut aussi être un ami pour
soi même et pas prendre soin de soi et
prendre soin de cette année qui est là
et qu'on accompagne au quotidien
j'ai un petit peu contre le
développement autocentré je trouve qu'il
ya un petit peu trop de narcissisme
parfois dans dans le développement
personnel qui serait un peu trop centré
sur soi même moi je dis non
quand on regarde bien le l'augmentation
du niveau de bien-être dans le corps il
se fait en étant en lien en étant en
lien avec les autres en étant en lien
avec l'environnement par nos cinq sens
en étant en lien avec ce que l'on fait
c'est pas soit c'est ce que l'on fait
oui c'est ce que l'on a fait on peut
leur apporter à soi mais c'est dans le
faire on trouve son bonheur et c'est
aussi en étant en lien avec les autres
qu'on trouve son bonheur
voilà alors c'est avec le bo c'est avec
le bien et c'est avec le bon
que vous pouvez développer votre
bien-être au quotidien en activant votre
dose alors pour pouvoir vous en souvenir
parce que ça c'est tout le problème le
cerveau n'est pas fait pour se souvenir
du niveau de bien-être
vous trouverez à la sortie des cartes
qui vous permettront de vous le rappeler
et moi je voudrais simplement vous
montrer que votre cerveau c'est ça et
qu'il est juste magnifique
regardez comment il fonctionne c'est pas
n'importe quel cerveau c'est votre
cerveau
au quotidien vous tous qui êtes ici
il
non
m